ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález alemania tiene
nuevo canciller federal se trata del
socialdemócrata olaf scholz quien con
395 votos frente a 303 en contra y 6
abstenciones fue elegido para suceder en
el cargo a la conservadora angela merkel
merkel le traspasó el poder tras 16 años
a quien fue su vice canciller por 3 años
y también su ministro de finanzas en una
última gran coalición de gobierno allí
en alemania a propósito de coaliciones
schulz gobernará junto a la llamada
coalición semáforo en la que sus aliados
serán los verdes y el partido liberal en
conjunto suman 416 escaños en el
bundestag el parlamento alemán de un
total de 736 escaños lo que les da
mayoría en el siguiente informe
preparado por la redacción de france 24
les contamos cómo transcurrió la sesión
de investidura y en berlín la capital
alemana y cómo estará conformado el
nuevo gobierno federal alemán
comienza el gobierno del socialdemócrata
olaf scholz el nuevo canciller juró el
cargo junto a sus ministros estoy
deseando empezar con el nuevo cargo
espero con ansias trabajar con este
equipo y hoy se marca un nuevo comienzo
para nuestro país voy a hacer todo lo
necesario el nuevo ejecutivo será el
primer paritario de la historia y
contará con ocho mujeres y ocho hombres
se le conoce como la coalición del
semáforo por la unión de
socialdemócratas liberales y verdes el
partido del canciller contará con siete
ministerios los verdes tendrán cinco
carteras como economía y energía
mientras que los liberales con cuatro
oficinas tendrán la vital de finanzas
este gabinete nace después de 59 días de
negociaciones tras los comicios del 26
de septiembre en este tiempo también han
establecido la ruta de gobierno aunando
sensibilidades sociales ambientales y de
incentivación de la economía
destacan ambiciosas ideas como la
descarbonización y modernización
económica abrir el voto a los jóvenes de
16 años avanzar en políticas de igualdad
con la autodeterminación de género y
ofrecer facilidades para obtener la
nacionalidad además la primera medida
consistirá en subir el sueldo mínimo de
96 a 12 euros un reto después de la
aplaudida era merkel quien considera que
tras la llegada de la pandemia alemania
se enfrenta al mayor reto de su historia
desde la segunda guerra mundial
este nuevo gobierno alemán está
compuesto como ya lo veíamos por tres
partidos es una composición inédita a
escala federal en ese país europeo sin
duda alguna es un nuevo capítulo el que
está comenzando en la historia política
de alemania y por supuesto pues también
surgen muchas preguntas qué rumbo tomará
alemania cómo podrá hacer la política de
alemania hacia américa latina' qué papel
va a jugar este país en la unión europea
cómo va a construir este nuevo gobierno
su relación con francia un país con el
que hay una disputa implícita por el
liderazgo dentro de la unión europea y
también teniendo en cuenta que francia
se enfrenta a elecciones presidenciales
el año que viene como vamos hacer la
relación con rusia con eeuu con china
con turquía y qué posiciones tomará
frente al resurgimiento o
posicionamiento de la extrema derecha en
alemania la migración la pandemia de
kobe 19 que está en uno de sus picos de
contagios más altos en este momento en
ese país del centro de europa y cómo
levantar de nuevo la economía que está
seriamente afectada también por la
crisis sanitaria a nivel mundial el
futuro de alemania bajo el nuevo
gobierno liderado por el canciller olaf
scholz nuestro tema de análisis y debate
aquí en france24 y para analizar este
tema hemos invitado al doctor johan en
kleinschmidt él es politólogo
investigador también de la universidad
cátolica de einstein y gortat y también
está con nosotros en la ciudad de
concepción en chile paulina astroza ella
es directora del programa de estudios
europeos de la universidad de concepción
allí en el sur de chile ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos sus comentarios
y preguntas también pueden hacerlo a
través de nuestras redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram en
twitter estamos como france24 bajo ese
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y preguntas en torno a este
tema pues comienzo entonces con el
doctor johan kleinschmidt allí en
alemania preguntándole por esta
coalición tres partidos este nuevo
gobierno alemán
con cargas equilibradas entre hombres y
mujeres que se puede esperar de este
gobierno tendrá que entenderse schulz
con estos compañeros de coalición que
muchos de ellos son muchos más jóvenes
que él y de pronto tendrá que dar muchas
concesiones cuál es su opinión
definitivamente esos tres partidos
tienen ideologías muy diferentes y así
como ya dijiste santiago hay
existencias las posibilidades para
disonancias incluso para conflictos al
mismo momento lo que tienen en común los
tres partidos es que ahora todos son
centristas todos son en ese sentido
todos quieren mostrar más continuidad
con el gobierno de angela merkel y eso
es algo que tienen en común la cuestión
es a dónde van a aparecer las primeras
disonancias podría ser la financiación
de algunos de los proyectos por ejemplo
en el sector de digitalización o de
medio ambiente cuando al mismo momento
han prometido no imponer nuevos
impuestos a eso sería un eje u otro
ejemplo sería la relación con rusia o
con china en las que el partido verde
por ejemplo es mucho más enfocado en la
alianza transatlántica
que entre los socialdemócratas hubo
mucho más simpatía para el
rusia
si ya paulina estroza en la ciudad de
concepción en el sur de chile también
para conocer sus impresiones paulina
bienvenida como siempre un gusto tenerla
en el programa y cómo será ese gobierno
que puede uno analizar de esta coalición
de tres partidos tantos temas sobre la
mesa tanto a nivel regional a nivel de
la unión europea a nivel internacional y
también algunas discrepancias dentro de
la misma alemania en torno a esta
conformación de tres partidos en esta
coalición
voy a saludarte de santiago
efectivamente está como es la primera
vez que existe esta coalición semáforo
por supuesto que hay muchas expectativas
y cuestiones o cuestionamientos
preguntas dudas respecto a cómo van a
funcionar porque yo ya estaba planteando
que existen diferencias entre ellos pero
respecto por ejemplo a la situación con
la unión europea han manifestado
expresamente los tres porque los tres
son
partidos muy pro unión europea que ellos
quieren profundizar esta relación con
los 27 quieren trabajar porque alemania
sigue siendo el gran motor de la
construcción europea por lo tanto desde
ese punto de vista
hay intereses bastante comunes tal vez
los acentos sean distintos porque
socialdemócratas y verdes quisieran
avanzar más en un tipo de integración
los liberales más aún teniendo la
cartera de finanzas que justamente es
y el dinero de los contribuyentes y que
justamente va a la unión europea' gran
parte de él bueno querrá también tener
algunas garantías respecto a lo que son
los socios en cuanto al gasto en cuanto
sobre todo ahora a la aplicación del
plan de recuperación económica entonces
ahí va a ver algo bastante interesante y
para terminar ellos han planteado un
concepto bastante importante que yo creo
que deberíamos mirar con atención porque
ellos hablan de una economía eco social
de mercado que en el fondo implica un
resumen de lo que cada uno estos colores
del semáforo de socialdemócratas verdes
y de liberales quieren poner en común
para que resulte este gobierno
tripartito y hacer primero la historia
de alemania y donde ahora el partido de
la canciller angela merkel pasa a ser
oposición
paulina pues profundicemos aprovecho
esta conexión entonces y sigo con usted
ya le doy la palabra alojen allí en
alemania hablemos de esa propuesta de
una economía eco social de mercado que
es lo que están proponiendo allí y esto
que significarían cambios para la
economía alemana que es el motor de la
unión europea y es el país que muchos en
europa tienen como referente de
industrialización de desarrollo
tecnológico es un gran referente para el
resto de los países sobre todo en el
este es un gran referente para el mismo
tiempo hay críticas sobre todo a la
gestión de angela merkel ya un retraso
de alemania en temas importantes como la
digitalización y la modernización del
funcionamiento del estado
además hay críticas y ha habido críticas
durante bastante tiempo a la gestión de
merkel de no haber invertido lo
suficiente en infraestructura pública y
lo que está planteando ahora justamente
este tripartito con este concepto y al
cual tuvieron que llegar a un acuerdo
porque tuvieron que negociar es por un
lado darle un sello social de cohesión
social al cual obviamente lo buscan los
socialdemócratas con los verdes pero al
mismo tiempo teniendo una visión de
mercado como es la que le dan los
liberales con una concepción en el cual
tienen que lograr un punto en común en
cuanto al desarrollo económico que lo
que buscan los que ponen el acento los
liberales pero con un desarrollo
sostenible cuidado del medio ambiente
medidas para defenderse el cambio
climático que justamente lo que fue lo
que negociaron y estuvo en este acuerdo
que dieron a conocer estos tres partidos
fue finalmente un acuerdo aumenta los el
sueldo mínimo pero no tanto serían
socialdemócratas y como lo querían los
verdes pero no se elimina el límite de
velocidad en las autopistas como lo
deseaban los verdes
o sea perdón no se establece el límite
de velocidad como lo querían los verdes
y los liberales no querían esta
limitación pero al mismo tiempo se toma
el acuerdo de invertir más fondos
públicos en infraestructura en
innovación y además en tecnología donde
está bastante atrasado alemania
comparado con otros países del mundo sí
comparado incluso con algunos estados
mucho más pequeños de la unión europea
como estonia y letonia lituania que son
países en el báltico ya es conocido a
nivel mundial en los problemas que tiene
alemania en entorno a sus redes de
internet y a las redes de telefonía y
johana allí en alemania en cómo ve usted
esta propuesta de esta economía con
social de mercado esta mezcla de tres
conceptos que hace acentos o énfasis en
tres puntos muy distintos pero de
acuerdo a lo que nos dice paulina pues
son puntos cruciales para el desarrollo
toda la economía en sí en un engranaje
estoy completamente de acuerdo con lo
que dice mi colega
básicamente la economía eco social de
mercado el eco son los verdes los social
son los socialdemócratas y el mercado
son los liberales así que es el intento
de hacer funcionar esas tres prioridades
lo que se facilita porque también los
liberales saben que van a necesitar
inversiones en infraestructura si la
economía de alemania va a mantener su
competitividad frente a pues aunque los
avances que han hecho otros países como
por ejemplo china pero también sus
socios en la unión europea eso podría
facilitar en el futuro
el encuentro de puntos de consenso entre
los tres a pesar de la incompatibilidad
ideológica que uno también puede
encontrar eso va a ser el juego la
búsqueda de un equilibrio entre los tres
eso va a ser lo interesante para
observar en la política económica de
este nuevo gobierno
interesante interesante cómo van a hacer
esos esfuerzos para negociar entre estos
tres partidos para sacar adelante estas
propuestas porque los tres
necesitan mantener esa cohesión para
poder aprobar en el bundestag todos
estos proyectos y yo quiero que hablemos
del personaje como tal de olaf scholz es
un personaje poco conocido en la escena
internacional muy conocido en la escena
interna de alemania en el mundo político
fue ministro de merkel y viene de
desempeñar varios cargos públicos entre
ellos la alcaldía de la ciudad de
hamburgo que es una de las ciudades más
importantes del país muchos lo ven
digámoslo de alguna manera como una
continuidad un poco del gobierno merkel
e incluso en la bbc lo titulaba hoy
diciendo que era increíblemente parecido
a merkel vamos a ver un gobierno es muy
parecido si lo cree usted así lo cree
así usted cree que va a empezar a tener
puntos particulares que lo van a empezar
a identificar ya darle una identidad a
este nuevo gobierno de los
socialdemócratas a esta coalición
básicamente esa impresión que son es muy
parecido a merkel parcialmente creo se
debe al hecho que ambos son oriundos de
la ciudad de hamburgo donde la cultura
particular
tiene ese estilo de una comunicación
austera no muy muy es crónica para
decirlo así no que caracteriza también a
merkel de expresarse de manera muy
tranquila
y eso tiene shorts también y eso
facilita esa impresión de representar
una continuidad con merkel que creo que
le ayudó bastante en la campaña más allá
de eso aún más allá de cuestiones de
estilo vamos a ver que el folk es parte
de un partido con prioridades bastante
diferentes que se dirige a un público
bastante diferente mucho más a un
público de él pues de la población de
clase media baja de obreros de
pensionistas no tanto al empresariado
por ejemplo scholtz que habló varias
veces con la prensa amarillista de
alemania la cual merkel básicamente
ignoró
así que vamos a vamos a ver ciertas
diferencias en términos del público al
cual se se va a dirigir de la manera
como se va a expresar aunque ese estilo
tranquilo
continuista eso sí va así en paulina sus
impresiones de olaf scholz que le dio en
septiembre pasado hacia triunfo a la
izquierda alemana después de que por
varios años había sido muy esquivo el
triunfo en las elecciones parlamentarias
allí en alemania cuáles son sus
impresiones
bueno en este hecho que se le compara
aunque éste dice que era el mas
merkeliano de los candidatos que habían
en la elección sea también porque
estamos comparando a olaf scholz con la
última en el último período de angela
merkel y angela merkel incluso al
interior de su propio partido fue
criticada por irse muy a la izquierda
muy al centro algunas encontraban que
incluso ya estaba adoptando
políticas que eran más propias de la
socialdemocracia o de los verdes que de
la derecha tradicional en alemania
entonces al estar comparando su último
pedido donde efectivamente ella da estas
señales donde también en materia de
temas llamados valóricos o respecto al
cambio climático a posiciones también en
contra de la ultraderecha donde fue muy
muy clara muy explícita haciendo incluso
caer el gobierno en turín ya que creo
que hace está esta percepción de que es
la continuidad de merkel por otro lado
fue el propio gasol quien proyectó esa
imagen en la campaña porque si hay algo
que los alemanes gustan mucho es de la
certeza es de no correr riesgos y esto y
es tener también una estabilidad y esa
estabilidad la que también quieren en
europa europa lo que quieren es que
justamente donde no hayan sobresaltos en
alemania o sea podrán haber otro
sobresalto en otros países pero no en
alemania
que todos reconocen la importancia que
tiene alemania dentro de la unión
europea entonces te dan estos factores
que hacen que se dé esto más allá del
estilo que hablaba johan y que
efectivamente es así creo que ninguno de
los dos es tiene una oratoria o seo es
carismático o existió nico al contrario
y eso también hace que uno tiende a
pensar que va a haber una continuidad
pero veremos ya
cómo van a afrontar la pandemia como en
afronta la recuperación económica sonido
desafío que ellos han planteado que eso
es para acabar direccionar a mí mi
siguiente pregunta paulina y es cuáles
van a hacer de pronto esas grandes
apuestas que se van a hacer en este
gobierno porque tal vez como ustedes lo
dicen puede que haya la misma forma y el
modo de contar las cosas hablarle al
público hablarle a los alemanes y
guardando un poco las formas que impuso
merkel a lo largo de estos 16 años pero
dentro de ese plan de gobierno hay
propuestas muy interesantes y también
hay muchas cosas internas necesarias
para hacer y hay temas urgentes la
pandemia ya lo decía yo la otra derecha
la migración el tema de medio ambiente
que es sumamente importante para esta
coalición y también la economía cual van
a ser cuáles van a ser entonces esos
puntos clave que le van a empezar a dar
una diferenciación en el manejo de los
de los temas yo creo que en primer lugar
bueno evidentemente la urgencia del día
es la pandemia alemania está actualmente
con índices muy altos de contagio y
además ya estaban adoptando se medidas
mucho más restrictivas angela merkel e
incluso antes de terminar no dio por
descartado que se pudiera llamar un
nuevo confinamiento se está discutiendo
la idea de establecer la vacuna
obligatoria lo que a grupos
que son bastante radicales dentro de las
formas de manifestarse no solamente en
alemania también en otros países no les
gusta entonces ahí van a tener un tema
el segundo tema es la recuperación
económica porque están los fondos del
fondo recuperación económica de la unión
europea
van a tener que establecerlo en estos
proyectos pero dentro de la recuperación
económica hay un tema importantísimo que
el sistema del gas el gas
hoy día hay crisis en cuanto a lo que
cuesta la energía sobre toda la energía
eléctrica y el tema del gas tienen una
alta dependencia de rusia entonces ahí
vamos a ver primero cómo va a ser esa
relación computing si va a ser
exactamente igual a la que tuvo angela
merkel con la construcción del gasoducto
de stringer 2 norte street 2 que fue un
tema que fue criticado también por los
verdes y el otro tema también que va a
ser interesante de ver qué tan duros van
a ser con países como polonia y hungría
por el no cumplimiento de los valores de
la unión europea y el estado de derecho
sí ya vamos a entrar en los temas de la
unión europea' complemento este tema de
política interna
tal vez completando esta lista de temas
que plantea paulina agregando también el
tema de vivienda hay una escasez de
vivienda en alemania y se ha encarecido
mucho sobre todo en berlín en la capital
que otros temas de usted usted que está
allí en alemán iconos en terreno los
temas nos puede ampliar mucho más
bueno algunos importantes que fueron
mencionados también tal vez uno debería
destacar temas culturales que no se han
mencionado mucho en la campaña aquí no
se están discutiendo ahora quiero pero
que representan aún un cambio más
tectónico más a largo plazo de la
cultura alemana por ejemplo hasta ahora
todos los cancilleres de alemania han
pertenecido a una de las dos iglesias oa
la luterana oa la católica que son que
representan la mayoría de los alemanes
es el primer canciller que es religioso
que no es miembro de una iglesia y
también los líderes en su coalición de
los liberales y de los verdes también
son y religiosos es interesante y que
obviamente representa a un país que
ahora ya no tiene de donde a la mayor
confesión religiosa ahora es no tener
una religión
y aún eso en una estructura en la que
las iglesias son organizadores en
grandes partes del estado de bienestar
en el sistema de cuidado para los
ancianos por ejemplo así que eso va a
significar que se van a hacer reformas
hacia un sistema más secular esas son
preguntas que también van a o se van a
abrir en el curso de reformas que se van
a volver necesarias en los próximos años
debido a la situación geográfica ideal
yo en complemento con otros temas que
han planteado ellos el aumento del
salario
a 13 euros 12 euros que son actualmente
están 960 euros ese es el salario mínimo
actual por ahora ellos plantean
aumentarlo a 12 también la venta de
cannabis con fines recreativos y la
facilitar la obtención de la ciudadanía
alemana para todos los migrantes que han
llegado recientemente que sabemos que
merkel fue muy abierta con este tema
pese a las que llovían sobre ella allí
en alemania que más se puede decir sobre
estos temas
a legalización de la marihuana es algo
que fue demandado por muchos expertos ya
desde hace mucho tiempo y en realidad
todos sabemos que la política represiva
contra las drogas no ha funcionado y no
va a funcionar en el futuro así que esto
es un paso muy necesario ampliamente
aceptado por la población y disputado
sólo por unos pocos conservadores
y lo mismo en realidad es el caso para
las reformas en el derecho de ciudadanía
lo hicieron básicamente más fáciles de
obtener la ciudadanía para inmigrantes
quienes han mostrado la capacidad para
por ejemplo para aprender el idioma o
integrarse al mercado liberal el mercado
laboral perdón y aún así que esos son
pasos
sobre los que hay un consenso amplio
dentro de la coalición en
lo que proponen ahora es que la
ciudadanía sea obtenía más fácilmente en
cinco años o en diez años dependiendo de
los casos pasemos a hablar del tema de
la unión europea el papel que va a jugar
a alemania con este nuevo gobierno con
los problemas que están lidiando la
unión europea en este momento el tema
energético en ese riesgo o amenaza al
estado de derecho que mencionaba paulina
en países como polonia como hungría y
también el tema crítico en la frontera
entre polonia y belarús y las relaciones
entre los países y quiero que dejemos a
francia un poquito de lado para que
hablemos de la relación berlín parís de
cara a las elecciones del año entrante
en en francia comienzo por paulina su
opinión sobre las relaciones con la
unión europea y el papel que tendrán que
jugar allí
bueno yo creo que en esto ya lo han
visto son países pro unión europea en
especial la socialdemocracia y los
verdes han planteado la idea de una
profundización en más temas de lo que
hoy día ya son parte de la unión en ese
sentido yo creo que el resto de los
países en especial aquellos que son que
creen en la integración están respirando
con cierto alivio porque aquí se
encuentran con una coalición que ya ha
dicho expresamente
están de acuerdo con este proceso va a
ser muy importante porque ellos han ya
lo han dicho en especial los verdes pero
también los socialdemócratas quien no se
puede permitir en la unión europea que
un país rompa las reglas en especial de
aquella que dice en relación con el
estado de derecho el respeto a los
derechos humanos la separación de
poderes
y en lo que está ocurriendo con hungría
y con polonia
se le critico angela merkel quien esto
fue le perdono muchas cosas a viktor
orbán en especial además que el partido
de viktor orbán el fidesz de hungría es
parte era parte del partido del grupo
popular europeo entonces nunca se le
expulsó finalmente del partido pese a
todo lo que estaba ocurriendo solo se le
suspendió y ahora se está exigiendo que
ellos cumplan con estos valores y si no
lo hacen sencillamente no tienen acceso
a estos fondos de la recuperación
económica y en general a los fondos
europeos y este gobierno ya ha dicho que
está de acuerdo en de esa manera
presionar a sus socios para cumplir con
con estos compromisos y obligaciones que
tienen en virtud de los tratados de la
unión europea que son fondos por unos
750.000 millones de euros destinados
para mejorar la economía de los países
de la unión europea a raíz de la crisis
sanitaria johan su opinión sobre el tema
de la unión europea
bueno como ya fue dicho todos los tres
partidos son muy decididamente pero
europeos van a apoyar a la unión europea
en esa pelea con polonia y hungría uno
podría decir que esos dos gobiernos son
están entre los grandes perdedores de
esta elección porque como ya lo mencionó
mi colega
el cdu sectores del cdu también el cs
apoyó mucho a viktor orbán con el
partido el hay enlaces entre el partido
del cdu él era muy cercano a helmut kohl
el ex canciller alemán y en ese sentido
perdí yo no a un aliado abierto pero
perdió a un gobierno que iba pues no le
iba a atacar muy abiertamente y ahora
aún
básicamente
habrá una política mucho más dura frente
a las tendencias autocráticas en polonia
en hungría también en esloveno y que hay
de la relación con francia el 10 de
diciembre schulz va a visitar parís va a
ser recibido por el presidente francés
emmanuel marco francia y alemania están
tratando como
peleándose a implícitamente ese
posicionamiento del liderazgo en la
unión europea a raíz de la salida del
reino unido- país con el que también
alemania va a tener que trabajar para
mejorar la relación tras el presi johan
como ve usted esa disputa entre parís y
berlín teniendo en cuenta las elecciones
francesas del año entrante
primero no lo veo como una disputa
obviamente hay diferencias en términos
de opinión en términos de prioridades
entre los dos países pero ambos países
saben que no pueden sin el otro y que
son realmente los socios más importantes
el uno para el otro cuando en eeuu los
republicanos podrían volver al poder
reino unido se fue de la unión europea y
aun ya no es un socio en realidad ya no
es visto como un socio importante y en
ese sentido
el poderío militar de francia es
esencial para la seguridad de alemania y
el poderío económico alemán es esencial
para francia también y en ese sentido yo
veo cierta disponibilidad de ambos de
permitir al otro cierta dominancia en su
respectivo tema no en francia en para
francia en el sector de defensa y
seguridad y para alemania en el sector
económico
ambos aun van a manejar una línea más
cuidadosa no van a entrar mucho por
ejemplo en conflictos con rusia y china
aunque se van a mantener leal a la
alianza transatlántica también y al sol
es definitivamente cree que el actual
presidente de francia síganlo lo
prefieren a cualquier alternativa y van
a tratar de no darle problemas en este
tiempo paulina su opinión si totalmente
de acuerdo creo que no hay una disputa
de poder en ningún caso son
complementarios cada cual tiene
históricamente ha tenido su espacio en
esto
también creo que el gobierno sólo va a
mirar con mucha mayor simpatía que sea
reelegido manuel macro
y hay un riesgo de la ultraderecha en el
caso de francia ultraderecha que ya no
sólo está representada por marie le pen
sino que hoy día también con se move que
en el fondo están planteando una opción
de dos opciones hoy día en las cuales se
están disputando ese voto que es
contrario a la unión europea que es
contrario a la integración que son
partidarios de las fronteras entonces
claramente e iván va a ser un gobierno
que no lo va a decir explícitamente no
va a intervenir
de esa forma pero que va a esperar con
ansia que quien sea el reelegido sea
manuel macro y juntos desafiar o hacer
frente a los desafíos no tan grandes que
tiene europa me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa paulina login
hagamos las conclusiones a grandes
rasgos como ven ustedes este futuro para
alemania para este nuevo gobierno
meto por ahí otra pregunta la relación
con américa latina será cercana será un
poco más cercana de lo que vivimos en
los últimos 16 años comienzo por johan
por favor tenemos un minuto
es una pregunta interesante no yo creo
que con los verdes y con los
socialdemócratas en ministerios como el
de ambiente como el de cooperación en
materias de desarrollo tal vez habrá más
interés en américa latina que si es
visto como otro continente democrático
que tiene interés en temas de
medioambiente de derechos humanos y eso
podría impulsar nuevas iniciativas y
paulina rápidamente su conclusión sin y
también el hecho del ministerio de
relaciones exteriores de manos de los
verdes da una posibilidad muy importante
a américa latina para poder tener una
mejor relación porque la verdad es que
es buena la relación con alemania en
general sea quien sea que esté en el
poder pero evidentemente eso va a abrir
un espacio sobre todo en el tema de
cambio climático y de cohesión social
pues a paulina en la ciudad de
concepción en chile muchísimas gracias
como siempre un gusto conversar con
usted allí en el sur de ese país del sur
de nuestro continente de alguien en
alemania muchas gracias también por
haber estado con nosotros dancing y a
ustedes muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros sigan con la programación de
france 24
[Música]